[Applaudissements]
but as tu commentes [ __ ] je suis
contente ça je suis content d'être là le
raider
amis pour fêter les grands l'air ok je
suis tellement content j'ai fait ce
qu'il faut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
combattant
la question de ces
au cours de cette voiture
qu'est ce que sera le meilleur matrix
match à bout beauté à cesser le bruit du
dos 1
alors si vous vous donne à je vais
mouvement là ça risque d'envoyer plus de
trucs sur la tête de ma mère j'ai
l'impression qu'un avion qui va décoller
faire mais il ya eu un bruit sur la vie
de ma mère âgée dia n'ose pas bien un
branchement saisit pas bien qui est le
2e patrick sébastien oui je le vois ah
oui c'est le deuxième sniper de
l'émission le problème c'est qu'ils se
croient très très drôle en ce moment
c'est louis dit jean michel maire un peu
du genre
[Applaudissements]
c'est que l'hiver est encore long et on
fait tourner ce leader je suis à vue new
look appelé à gold que je suis bien à
l'âme américaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'il sera plus réduit
c'est pas du tout ils ont pas compris a
pas être maîtres le prompteur à moi je
vais pas sans témoin en fait il connaît
pas une parole ces semaines de repos
donc en fait ce qu'il faudrait faire mon
froc sais que mon chéri toi tu es toi
t'es pas la donne est là et toute chose
comme ça merci franck ce que tu veux que
je réalise l'émission tu veux dire on va
faire avec vous le dis parce que le
producteur mais là pour les amis merci
ok ensuite celui de caméras on switch
attention le troisième a dit une femme
elle est magnifique on même si tu n'es
plus belles de france et de navarre
isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
je souhaiterais jours
salle
le
ça fait du bien
pour l'instant pour l'instant vous êtes
la meilleure et je vous fais des
interviews
vous me répondrez rixe matin commence
arras profite à ses shows à chaud sans
vacanciers ça
[Musique]
cependant vous êtes dans l'erreur
tu peux pas savoir si l'uci merci merci
isabelle gleize
[Applaudissements]
je suis là sauf à l'attestation j'ai
poussé un coup de gueule côte où se
tendent à un petit bobo
déjà c'est à nous le
[Musique]
maxime ghani 6 papa tu sais qu'on tienne
compte m white faire un petit cadeau
c'est de sortir mon plus gros tubes
table y compris la blague du gros teams
à l'elysée qu'à la chanson
tout le mois
la petite famille
les deux cet arrêt crise en se
c'est l'autre on se
[Musique]
le soir où tu as de quoi
[Applaudissements]